I want to dig into a particular element
of what might be the eventual Republican
/ Trump tax reform plan I got a lot of
emails specifically about Republicans
considering capping 401k contributions
at twenty four hundred dollars a year
and I want to talk about what the micro
and macro impact of that would be who is
this good for who is this bad for etc
and to understand that we need to start
with well what's a 401k 401ks are
retirement savings plans and they're
sponsored by employers sometimes the
employer offers a matching contribution
of maybe 1% of your salary sometimes
they don't sometimes they will
contribute to your 401k regardless of
whether you contribute to it but the
important part from the end user from
the employees perspective is that you
put pre-tax money in your 401k so it
reduces the amount you pay on taxes each
year if you earn $50,000 and you put
$2,000 in your 401k you only pay taxes
as if you had earned $48,000 the 2,000
that you put in the 401k are tax
deductible good that's the basics of it
you do pay the taxes when you use the
money right so when you retire
presumably or before if you want to pay
a penalty to get the money out early you
then pay taxes on the money you take out
of the 401k as if it were income at the
time okay
Donald Trump tried to deny initially
that Republicans are considering
reducing the cap on contributions to
401ks to $2,400 Trump went to Twitter
initially and tried to deny this by
saying quote there will be no change to
your 401 K this has always been a great
in popular middle class tax break that
works and it stays now Trump lies all
the time so who cares what Trump tweets
but a few days after that tweet he
backtracked and said actually I am
willing to negotiate on this issue of
the 401 K limit so let's for a second
consider what seems to be the reality
which is that there are some versions of
the tax plan where it would be explored
cutting the maximum that you can
contribute to the 401 k plan
to $2,400 now a relevant question is
well cutting it to $2,400 from what and
that is the next thing we have to talk
about in 2017 the contribution limit for
401ks is $18,000
next year the contribution limit for
401k is is scheduled to go up to
eighteen thousand five hundred dollars
so this is a major cut and it is Bigley
regressive and regressive not in the
you're part of the regressive left sense
regressive in the tax sense right it
will impact the middle class way more
than it will impact the rich and that
happens in a number of ways if you make
fifty thousand dollars the tax savings
provided by the deductibility of 401k
contributions really makes a difference
to you if you make 50k and you put five
thousand dollars in a 401k that saves
you one thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars in taxes because you're at the
twenty five percent federal tax rate
that's about a hundred dollars a month a
hundred dollars a month is real money
for someone that's grossing fifty
thousand dollars if you live in
Massachusetts you're saving another 5.3
percent on your state income tax that's
another two hundred and sixty-five
dollars so we're talking about fifteen
hundred dollars a year in your pocket if
you earn fifty thousand dollars live in
Massachusetts and contribute five grand
to your 401k compare that to someone
earning four hundred thousand dollars a
year if you earn four hundred thousand
dollars a year and you contribute the
full eighteen thousand dollars that
you're allowed even at the thirty five
percent tax bracket that you'd be in
that eighteen thousand dollars saves you
sixty three hundred in taxes if you're
earning thirty three thousand dollars a
month the way you would be if you earned
four hundred thousand dollars a year
what is five hundred bucks a month do
for you you're not making big decisions
about lifestyle based on those five
hundred bucks
you're probably saving a lot of that
money so it doesn't make a big
difference for you and you're not going
to use that money in a stimulative way
that also explains to us why this is
good if you have a tax plan like Donald
Trump has
that you're trying to cut taxes for the
rich on and trying to cut taxes for
corporations if you reduce the cap on
401k contributions you shift tax burden
to the middle class that allows more
leeway to cut taxes for the rich and for
corporations even though those changes
would still explode the deficit don't
get me wrong now the other reason why
this is hugely regressive is that if
you're really rich you have more
sophisticated tools available to you
than 401ks
anyway you can use self funded pensions
you can use there's a long laundry list
of tools that there and vehicles that
the very rich have so you're less likely
to even be using a 401k in this way if
you're a very rich person and lastly
this is a total budget gimmick remember
how I said at the beginning of the
segment when you put money in a 401k you
don't pay taxes on it now it reduces
your taxable income you do eventually
pay taxes on it though right when you
pull that money out in retirement you
pay taxes on it then if you lower the
cap on 401k contributions you will get
more taxes paid now and you will get
less in taxes paid when these same
people retire that's really good for the
current administration but it's not a
net gain you're just gonna have the
taxes paid later on it'll be some other
president's problems some other
economies some other presidents economy
that's going to have to deal with that
and what people will do is they'll move
some of those contributions from a 401k
to something an ID IRA type for example
where you pay the taxes now but then you
get the money out tax-free in retirement
so it's a way for this president to
shift the tax burden into the present
and away from retirement but for the
economy it's not actually a tax benefit
in the net we're talking about something
that is nominally zero sum and then we
can talk about well if you're expecting
a higher or lower tax bracket in
retirement that could impact it but then
we're getting into a more finely sliced
analysis so what you're doing is raiding
the coffers of future revenue for
revenue now by limiting how much money
people can save now on their taxes
with these contributions this is not
universally favored by Republicans there
are Republicans who understand that the
401k is a is a useful vehicle for lots
of middle-class Americans so we'll see
what happens and of course I don't want
a miss state there are tons of people
who are not in the middle class and who
don't even have access to 401ks or don't
know the first thing about them and
that's a whole other issue and we've
been talking about that but the point
here is to explain the economic
implications at the micro the individual
taxpayer level and the macro level of
capping 401k contributions lower and I
hope that I've done that and feel free
to discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our EDD I tea and if my explanation has
not been clear let me know on reddit and
I'll clarify today's program is
sponsored in part by movement watches
I'm wearing my movement watch today
everywhere I go people look at it they
say that's a really nice watch where'd
you get that and I tell them movement
watches it was started by two broke
college kids that wanted to wear stylish
watches they'd go into the department
stores they'd see watches that they
liked and the price tag would be four
hundred to five hundred dollars so by
cutting out the middleman and selling
directly online movement watches start
at just ninety five dollars classic
design quality construction styled
minimalism and over a million watches
sold in over 160 countries you can get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to M V M t.com
slash Pakman my watch has a really great
clean design that I like and it attracts
a lot of attention and now you can step
up your watch game go to MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman and join the movement